I think about Kim you've been you look
beautiful by the way I love the hair
thanks I just got it done so thank you
thank you I appreciate that all right
have you been watching the episodes back
yes how are you feeling
um
I know I feel like from the first season
and then the season I feel like people
are starting to see my personality more
and to see like what kind of person I
really am is it always good no it's not
always good but I'm always going to be
me and I've said that for the past two
years I'm just gonna I'm gonna be Kim
you either love me or you hate me you
know if you know I love you right I'm
probably gonna cry
I know you love it you know how much I
love you I love you too babe like more
than you probably even know I know you
love me okay
and we've been through a lot in two
years we've been through a lot
are you telling me this I know I'm gonna
ask you a question
will you marry me thank you you recently
proposed to Usman what led you to
propose to him although his mom didn't
give you her blessing
I just to me it's like why wouldn't I
have proposed to him everything in our
relationship has been so unconventional
right like I met him online I went to go
see him film a music video about another
woman I um everything has been
everything in our relationship is
unconventional all of this talk about
the second wife and children and
marriage everything's unconventional you
know I've been in Nigeria before this
and um we spent a lot of time together
and I just felt in my heart I felt if I
do things from my heart and I I did it
even I wanted him to know even without
if we never get his mother's blessing
that I truly love him yeah and I wanted
him to know that and that's why I did it
and I think more women should do it like
why the hell not why is it always up to
the man to each his own to each his own
that's what you propose and it seemed as
if your intention was more so to make
sure that he knows you love him before
he goes to see this other woman you know
it's a kind of
I guess out of fear just you wanted to
get it done before you lose potentially
lose him I swear to God it's not I did
it because I wanted him to know maybe
okay maybe a little bit I chose to
propose tonight because regardless of
what his mom says I want him to know
that I love him so much
and to make sure that I'm a priority and
to make sure that he loves me the most
especially now
I kind of just want to like seal the
deal with them before he goes to meet
this other woman do you know how awkward
that was for me I know it was a test
from his mom but I feel like
I loved him and I still love him and I
wanted to I just really wanted him to
know like regardless of anything even if
we just turned out to be best friends
you know that I'm just gonna be here for
the Long Haul like I'll always support
you always regardless of anything that
happens I want you to know that I'm
always going to be here I'm always I'm
not going anywhere you told him no
matter what happens I will be here I'm
like Kim I thought we agreed you were
first wife and nothing else so what do
you mean no matter what happens so you
meant even if you all don't end up
together right that's exactly where I'm
at and I I'm sticking to my guns so and
I know everybody's like okay Kim she
finally got you know but I have to skip
to my guns on certain things I've um I'm
sacrificing a lot I don't know why Usman
doesn't think I am but I'm I'm sacrifice
we know roll the eyes again
honey trust me right and I feel like I
have to stick to my guns on certain
things like I said in previous relations
chips you know I was always pushed
second and I'm not going to have that
happen I don't care who it is and how
much I love somebody I deserve happiness
and love too and I deserve it on my
terms as well yeah well tell me this
what is it about Usman that makes you
want to marry him because I mean I want
to get married I have my list or you
know I believe people have mixed
feelings feelings about the list but I
do but there are certain qualities that
I look for in a man so what is it about
Usman that has you wanting to spend the
rest of your life with him
he's just he's really funny like I don't
think people understand what a good
sense of humor he has you know and then
like I said when I went to Nigeria we
found we have so much in common and I
know it sounds crazy as hell but we have
so many like we like the same TV shows
we like the same food we like it's just
like so much it's like it's like I
really felt like I'm at my soul mate you
know and I really felt like I've never
in my whole 52 years of living have felt
so comfortable with another human being
like all this makeup right now he likes
it when I'm just Dark Circle cam my hair
pulled back you know what I mean and I
just feel like
seeing him and knowing where he came
from it just made me love him that much
more like we went and we fed
um the poor and the homeless on when I
went on my private trip and just to see
like I want to give me like that's what
I've always wanted is somebody that is
just as giving and such as kind-hearted
as I am yeah what do you say to people
who feel as if you're just infatuated
with Usman and the idea of marrying a
superstar okay
um
okay I
okay I would see like I've been to
Nigeria like I said before privately
okay and um
I got to really like know him without
all of this you know and it was just him
and I and Airbnb for three weeks and it
was amazing and I really got to know
Usman you know like more than I knew
before because it was just him and I
because you have to remember the first
time we met in person was on camera
right so this was just him and I 24 7
for three weeks you know and it was
amazing and it's not about that anymore
it's not about like oh because he's a
singer or because he's a rapper or
because as I like to call him
International Superstar you know it's
not it's not it's more than that now
like I've invested so much time and he's
invested so much time and effort you
know and I felt like when I proposed to
him I don't look at him and I know
everybody teases me because sometimes I
do call him Soulja Boy but more now it's
like Soulja Boy relaxed no but it's like
we'll pump your break soldier boy but um
but now it's like this is like an honest
to God relationship okay okay well I
feel like in every relationship you know
we have needs every person has needs
from a viewer's standpoint sometimes I
worry that your needs aren't necessarily
being met and there's a lot of
compromise you're doing does Usman meet
your needs do you feel as if that's the
case
I feel that sometimes the relationship
can be really one-sided and I feel like
sometimes I'm like God I'm the one
traveling 27 hours to come see you I'm
the one with the swollen ankles I'm the
one you know that's coming like that
sacrifice to like to be okay with you
taking a second life or whatever the
case may be you know and I feel like he
just sees it from his point of view you
know what I mean like it's very very
one-sided most the time it's like okay
oh this is this Usman the Usman marriage
or is this the Kim and Eastman you know
what I mean is this us is this our
engagement or is it are you thinking
about my thing like how it's going to
feel for me
I want to can I clear something up while
we're here and talking about this let's
do it
I want people to understand with this
whole second life thing I still feel the
same way I do I feel like it would I
would be remiss if I did not let him go
and have a child I don't want to
surrogate I my son is 27 years old you
know I I saw certain things that I was
just like I didn't I really don't mean
it like that like certain things I had
said you know in the past episodes and I
want to make that clear I would never
make another woman feel like handmaid's
tale okay it's not like that it's my
perception of what Gooseman has told me
now I've done research I know what I'm
getting into and it's a lot better does
that make sense yeah I want I want to
add more into the second wife situation
because there there's a lot there I have
a fan comment April says
wait April alone April says quote Kim
you're very attached to being the first
wife but it seems to me sharing a
parenting role with a second wife would
create a deeper Bond yes I have I have
thought about that and things have
changed since then and I would totally
be in the child's life totally even if
it's just you know my Christmas here or
whatever you know I would totally I'm
not raising it but I mean I would be
more supportive than how I've been in
the past so is this what you want though
you know like because that's what goes
in my head is this the life you imagine
for yourself or I don't know hell no
sometimes because I'm learning myself in
relationships sometimes we hold on to
stuff because it's comfortable and we
like the idea of it but it's really not
what we want you know
um I um I have I love who's been enough
to let this happen I love him enough to
let it happen I have learned that I have
to pick my battles I
um kind of step to the side when it
comes to this subject a little bit but
we've talked and we have Clarity on how
it's going to be we have a plan that's
for us I can't really say it right now
so I um it's it's it's difficult I feel
like in every relationship that you have
to you have to give and take and I feel
like this is all of you giving and I'm
but I'm not going to give too much more
so
I think that's the double-edged story
with being such a giver you know
sometimes you can give your soul yes I
said it in our last interview it's a
blessing and a person
[Music]
foreign